also true we welcome you back to CBS
mornings it has been five years since a
bombshell investigation uncovered
Decades of abuse and harassment
allegations rather against media Mogul
Harvey Weinstein the reporting fueled
the metoo movement and earned New York
Times journalist Jody Cantor and Megan
Tui a Pulitzer Prize Jody joins us in
the studio just after the breaking story
we all remember this Weinstein is now
serving a 23-year sentence for rape and
sex assault in New York is on trial
right now in Los Angeles on additional
sex crime charges now the new film she
said is out today you must go see this
movie it tells the story behind the
investigation in this clip one of
Weinstein's former production assistants
tells Jody cantor's character about the
agreement she made with the Weinstein
Company to keep her allegations quiet
foreign letters
[Music]
I had to have their permission
if I wanted to contact a therapist
speak to an accountant
account I was never to speak to any
other media now or Hereafter existing
about it
Jody
this is bigger than White's team this is
about the system protecting abusers
I want you to take these
and I want you to use them
Jody Cantor was also a CBS News
contributor joins us now with actor Zoe
Kazan who I think you nailed it she
played Jody in the movie Welcome to you
both thank you first can I say guys
bravo bravo bravo Jody I have to start
with you because we all know this story
you've been here many times talking
about it and I felt I know the story
I I'm trying to explain why it was so
emotional watching it on the screen and
I think because you really took us
behind the scenes you and Megan took us
behind the scenes about the work that
you put in and what it took to get the
story why was it such an emotional time
for those of us who have seen this movie
well I'm so grateful to Zoe and the rest
of the team that made this film because
what they've done is they've taken
frankly the inspiration that Megan and I
feel in our work and have put it on the
big screen I think you see The Bravery
of these sources the the the women are
not shown as pure victims they're shown
as these adult women with a difficult
choice to make about you know are they
going to cooperate with this
investigation why should they there's
enormous risk for them but then what I
think you also see is the power of the
truth and the feeling that you know we
really can confront a bully we we just
have to do it together was it emotional
for you Zoe and I'm wondering how you
nailed Jody so well first I want to know
was it emotional and how you how you
captured her yeah I mean I I cried
reading the book when when the women
decided to go on the record
um I felt the same way reading the
script I sort of cried every time I read
it
um I think it's just very emotional to
see women stand in their truth and their
power and to see an institution like the
New York Times stand behind them and put
heft behind those individual voices
um you know watching women be believed I
think is very powerful did you study
Jody though did you meet with her did
you watch the interviews I mean I think
I sound like a stalker I'm like I tried
to absorb her Essence
um we got to spend time together in a
very chill way we're both Brooklyn moms
we like spend time with our kids we went
to dinner together but you two did nine
you two didn't know each other no we've
never met but when I first met Jody I
felt like oh I could have known her
already like there was a real sense of
familiarity and she and and her husband
Ron are so inspiring and such impressive
people but getting to know them felt
like very easy like they just were so
welcoming and generous and let me kind
of peek into their lives and ask all
sorts of nosy questions yeah there was a
decision Zoe was very probing there were
times when you asked me things where I
was like I could tell you the truth but
it might end up on screen there was a
decision made not to show Weinstein's
face how do you feel about that
the book so the movie is based on a book
we wrote right and the book is called
she said
it's called she said for a reason right
because in those two little words are so
many multiple layers of meaning and man
I just think this film unpacks that so
beautifully and what you know it is a
story about feet there are some men who
helped in a really powerful way but at
the end of the day this is a book and a
film about female narration and the
power of using your voice
um Jody you mentioned how this film
accurately depicts not just how hard it
was for these women to come forward but
then also go on the record which are two
completely different things
how difficult was it in real time when
that was happening
so difficult
you're asking people gone real risk and
you can't disguise that you know one of
the scenes in the film that's the truest
to life for me is when Ashley Judd calls
me to to cause my character who plays
herself in the movie Ashley plays
herself in the movie and she's you know
I think what Ashley and Zoe are doing in
that scene is sharing with the world
something very special that happened in
real life which is that this woman put
her career and her reputation on the
line for the sake of other women and I
try to be very professional in the
workplace and in my conduct at the times
but I got to tell you I mean I I broke
down
crying because for me it was the first
time I really knew the investigation was
going to work and I think you can like I
think you did such a beautiful job of
showing the layers of emotional reaction
kind of beneath the professional like we
saw it in real time have you seen Zoe
changes in Hollywood since the article
came out
we've had some really concrete changes
like having an intimacy coordinator
who's sort of like a stunt coordinator
but for any intimate contact on screen
um having codes of conduct that we agree
upon before we start filming having
anti-harassment workshops within the
cast and crew but I think you have only
to open a newspaper to see how far is a
society we have to go yes and I think
that one of the messages of the film is
that Collective action can have an
impact that
um
I don't know that there's a power in
standing together and that like she said
to take down a bully you don't need to
be a powerful person
yes Jody you talk about it so coherently
and just you know almost distantly but
what you went through you and Megan you
had death threats your daughter asked
you what is rape I mean there's so many
things that we saw in your personal life
I'm in awe I'm in awe and bravo bravo to
you Bravo Public Service well done well
done Jody cantorin's always Kazan we
thank you she said as I said is out in
theaters today please run don't walk to
see this movie